[Music]
in better pet owners news what these
wills kicked our dogs
Jesus we want to make them better right
so they got started low somewhere but
that's like your your next like minus
ones that probably like Brandon I don't
know that's probably really bad yes
somebody so somebody who's like who
kicked the dog that morning like man I
got to be a better pet owner yeah I
serious a maybe maybe you could really
know they might walk next to a puddle
and they see the reflection in the
puddle we got a reprieve who am i
submitted by poopa T school
hey yeah we do put it we keep loop we
check on your part yeah what this song
Koopa do scooping yes yes is actually a
Chinese city has rolled out a Social
Credit System to keep pet owners in
check good good for you China Social
Credit System that's insane so remember
we talked about the Social Credit System
well I don't know if yeah it was like a
long time a little bit vague lis
remember it that's something to do with
like kind of like a credit score but for
your behavior almost first being a
better start in your line that's so wait
no you ain't you Lynn oh yeah yeah I
watch all stuff I'm like a crazy fan
that somehow I ended up on camera cool
[Laughter]
so yeah they're launching this credit
system or actually they've already
launched it and it's in this city
Chinese city of geniune Union Union and
it requires anybody who has a dog
jingyan
for or mother [ __ ] a free one gen5 yeah
so they're saying that anyone that has a
dog is required to register with the
police and only one dog is permitted per
person and they'll have just like their
children QR code not anymore they you
bet it'll have a QR code on the collar
and then so everyone starts off with a
dozen points
and then points are deducted for
different infractions like walking a dog
without a leash or a tag that's dope
not cleaning up poop yes that's
something or being reported for
disturbing
oh no that one's kind of haven't can be
bad cuz then they have people starting
to piss me off in South Pasadena some
people there's one specific [ __ ]
that's not picking up at there's dog cuz
there's only it's always in the same
spot same long silence the same [ __ ]
yeah I'm like in a cycle [ __ ] different
day it's like a dog that you know those
dogs that don't sit and [ __ ] they just
walk in the trail so yeah there's like
oh there's a few so it's always the same
spot so this dog me love starts walking
before he's done [ __ ] sometimes do
yes I saw that the best is when they
were eating hair or something and so it
dangles yeah this is kind of tight
because then I could always see like the
same old and so like you [ __ ] bow
beater and they're like well we taking
about thought better than new buddy you
got 12 step system that's pretty crazy
I'll coach no y'all think this is really
cool but you know sometimes I'll come on
here and conspiracy bows comes out yeah
I like this but like seriously though
like obviously this is gonna work for
pet owners so let's say in five years
they're like well let's do this with
humans all I'm down you are my spirit
animal that's exactly how I think about
everything they did a black mirror
episodes like that do you all remember
that where they had where they could
rape people only one I saw but like
seriously that's the thing they did
launch that back what yeah but but it's
like out by the government this by the
government so they're gonna be like this
helps to make everyone nice with the dog
so then we're gonna make it nice with
the people right 2014 everybody's about
to be fake as [ __ ] I'll tell you why
I'll tell you I like this so on the news
recently here are miss Dolittle she
couldn't put it like this you go there
so they give you they give you 12
chances to be a good dog owner right you
[ __ ] up they take up they take off these
points and then you take your dog away
right for wheter we were watching on the
news the other day there's this family
that cut off their son's dick beat the
[ __ ] out of them like stab them all this
stuff
I know some people they shouldn't be
parents yeah so if parents had a 12-step
system then they would think twice about
being really really bad parents because
there's so many different ways to pay
out there there's a lot very vague about
who's really controlling this whole
system but yeah that's the video you
said you watch with the Social Credit
well no that's scary for dogs though for
people though dude what if they don't if
they there's some stupid standard for
picking up your kid and they see you
pick up Tyco with one hand and under his
armpit and they're like that's wrong
because you could discombobulated or
dislocate or what [ __ ] things that I
gotta do when there's no cameras wrong
yeah there's so many ways though like
there's so many different ways of people
parent like what if somebody doesn't
agree with the religion you chose for
your child or that you didn't let your
child freely pick their religion and
they're like less points like that's not
[ __ ] fair [ __ ] that yeah your son
says that he's a girl and you're not
like helping him along even though he's
3 so like you know what we're taking
your kid what about like a really really
basic [ __ ] poof
Children's license driver's license
right works where the questions are like
this how many times a day should did you
feed your kid and it's one is this cool
once a month Oh three times a day when
you feel like it then you have to be a
lot are to fail this and if you can't
you can't have a kid that's a hard test
that's hard what yeah well three times a
day is is part of the but the other
tracks are so ridiculous no the third
one sounded most plausible to me because
I eat three times a day and I'm I'm huge
yeah and then this is small so shouldn't
interest eat like okay that's a bad
example how many times a day should I
change its diaper at once every five
years I changed my never needs to be
changed or snap the baby upside the head
so you're saying take a test as soon as
you find out you're pregnant or even
before you gotta apply to be parents
you're saying and yet to be Minotaur
proof
take baby from the parents if they're
not on a regular diaper change they
adopt kids right that's what you're
saying but before they connected yeah so
before you can be a foster parent or
adopt kids
they got a screen you and whatever
because there's a lot of dumbasses out
there so if there's a something that can
really just weed out some really bad lot
arts to like give me like a test run
like in high school when you have a bag
of flour you have to take care of they
should give you a fake baby and then you
pass yeah well I failed that taste cause
I've made cookies out of that [ __ ] so
why the how to do the egg drop leg drop
with the egg drop were you like you got
to wrap an egg and like [ __ ]
something comfortable and throw it off
the roof what was your class do you want
to see if you can take care of something
like roof that's probably science uh
yeah I think what's physics or some [ __ ]
but I'm like dude I didn't get [ __ ] out
of this lesson other than I broke a
couple eggs
yeah I had to do that but we didn't have
like a it was like we had to create our
own kid or whatever and then what ended
up happening with me was it was my turn
to take it home I had shared custody
with my partner in the group and like I
came home from school and I had a bad
day and I was mad at my fake kid and I
understood my mom struggle and I forgave
her you know I was you know not an egg
no I did it but I thought about it and I
was like I get it now I understand I had
a baby I don't have a kid right now but
I'm already picturing kicking my [ __ ]
kids ass not even born yet mm-hmm yeah
like I'm already picturing this child to
find me right now according to Bart's
test you wouldn't be allowed to have two
well that I'll pass that test with
flying [ __ ] colors oh you are going
to set the bar really really low that
were like because to me there's people
so David knows his his approach to it is
not okay but he's worried about if you
could control himself or not there's
other people that actually think it's
okay to beat the [ __ ] I don't get that's
why I laugh at all the [ __ ] where it's
like it's like your babies chose you
that the angel pick the parents and I'm
like what Angels gonna pick I will beat
the [ __ ] out of my own kid like he's a
[ __ ] I'm going down there yeah like I
don't know who you take that gamble
because I'm all talk
most likely I'm going to coddle this
child is going to be a piece of [ __ ]
let's see what you got my character you
never know might be a tough kid I hope
so but daddy wasn't very tough either so
look it's not gonna happen
you're gonna make a lot of excuses and
be fed then lose weight of these dog
owners Social Credit System they're
saying that they're gonna it's gonna be
fully operational by 2020 yeah but yeah
it's kind of weird because the
government doesn't really provide a lot
of details as to who exactly is in
charge of this whole thing but they are
saying though in that one city that
because that's when the so last year is
when the program was introduced and 1430
dog owners had been fined and 122 of
them lost the full dozen points which
then means that they lost or because of
the other dogs damn but then they also
have a chance to pass an exam and get
their pet their pets back kind like when
you lose custody your kids are pretty
poor in like classes that's kind of what
they're doing so you're saying that they
do this for the dogs and also for the
people right now mmm for people well the
people thing has been happening since
2014 yeah so the people have QR codes
and all that [ __ ] already to our codes
but I remember just from off the top of
my memory I remember saying it was
something like a Social Credit System
but I forgot the consequences aren't
like they take your kids away or
anything like that no it's more of just
like I think got a peer-to-peer rating
system oh I don't like that ya know like
both said it can be exploited and I can
see that well I don't [ __ ] bitter
guys that are it's like hey do you want
to go get a drink you're like no thanks
oh I've gotten a lower uber rating
before because some like I cuz I don't
drive so I take uber all the time I have
consistently like had times where
somebody will ask me for my number like
ask me something and then I just get a
one-star rating from them because of
that
yeah it definitely happen because you
never because once you get out of the
car you never see that driver again and
they [ __ ] hate you just one star like
a perfect [ __ ] uber rating right I go
to [ __ ] France Perry mm-hmm we don't
even talk to each other I came back I
was like hello you smell like [ __ ] given
five stars of [ __ ] thank you right these
bonds jerk huh I should say thank you in
English
because I don't like I don't I don't
want to like pretend like I know the
language thank you and all of a sudden
boom I got a four point eight I'm like
somebody gave me a four stop who gave me
a four star dude no this is some four
star rating I just don't want to butcher
the language is so beautiful yeah it is
nice yeah yeah by making fun of the
language right through mocking he gave
me only your mark
yeah can't even try to do it seriously
this all right but if I try to make fun
of the language it sounds way better
that's how I say if you want to learn
language trying to make fun of it yeah
because I don't you make it sound
authentic a spud very popular in a
Mexican restaurant and I want to he does
I just say hey good taquitos cuz cuz
I've tried a couple times from Ikea and
it seems like I'm making fun of it duh
so you do with your feet no it actually
sounds more authentic that way I know
but I'm like dude I can't do this
correctly I felt metaphor to cut out
yourself to Keating's I see David again
dead the other loves more thought see
the card up there sounds if I try to say
that authentic is gonna sound terrible
right obviously there's a dead that's
why I just said good there wasn't much
David from yesterday's yes miss Delmas
the Miss days
[Music]